Who's [music] got the guts
to bring back
the crusade?
>> [singing]
>> Were the Crusades a glorious and heroic
adventure,
or were they a shameful and disastrous
failure? I was recently asked a version
of this question. And we we had another
historian Dan Jones on the show to talk
about the Crusades. It didn't sound like
the way he told it, at least, like a
particularly successful or happy story,
really. Now, you can see my response
around the 1-hour mark of that
Triggernometry interview, but I wanted
to make a more focused and dedicated
video, this one, to give a fuller, more
detailed explanation. For this is a very
important question, one that comes up
often, and one with important
ramifications. If, for example, the
Crusades were great failures, what on
Earth should anyone find inspiring about
them? To be brief, the answer comes down
to numbers. The Crusaders lost, and the
Muslims won, ultimately because of
numbers. Large Muslim numbers against
small Christian numbers. And what caused
this imbalance? Simple. Unlike the cold
logic that fueled history's Muslim
conquests, the Christian desire to take
and hold of the Holy Land was motivated
by purely idealistic reasons, and these
ultimately proved too impractical to
sustain. Consider, history's Muslim
conquests were wholly pragmatic and
followed the usual model. Muslim armies
always targeted whichever infidel
populations were closest to them.
That's because all non-Muslims were
enemies, and their conquests proceeded
wherever it was most convenient for
Muslims. By contrast, the Crusader
effort was not aimed at conquering
infidels, per se, but at securing and
holding a specific and highly important
piece of real estate, the Holy Land,
where Jesus walked, taught, died, and
was resurrected. To better understand
all this, let's take a closer look at
how the Muslim conquests of history
unfolded. Beginning from their Arabian
homeland, Muslim forces moved outward by
subduing their most immediate neighbors.
To the northwest, lay Christian Syria
and Egypt. To the northeast, Zoroastrian
Persia.
Rather than bypassing these regions in
pursuit of distant objectives, Muslims
first focused on conquering and fully
consolidating these adjacent
territories. Only after Syria, Egypt,
and Persia had been secured, did Muslim
armies proceed further west into North
Africa, and further east into Central
Asia and India. Each conquest
strengthened the next. Regions were not
merely occupied, but brought into the
House of Islam, the Ummah. This
sequential, contiguous expansion ensured
that Muslim forces always operated with
secure lines of communication and an
ever-growing base of manpower and
resources immediately behind them. In
other words, Muslim armies never flung
themselves deep into hostile territory
with enemies surrounding them. They
advanced step by step, always within
easy reach of their own world, friendly
populations, supply networks, and
reinforcements, as well as easily
defensible territory which they could
retreat back to in the event of a
setback. Consider the Muslim conquest of
Spain.
Rather than try to subdue that Christian
peninsula prematurely, Muslim forces
first spent their energies conquering
and consolidating all of North Africa,
which for decades put up a stubborn
defense, particularly its Berber
populations. Only once that region was
firmly under Muslim control and the
Berbers Islamized, did the Arabs invade
Spain from their nearest African base,
Morocco, in 711, some 80 years after the
initial conquests of Syria and Egypt. By
then, Islam had been established all
across the southern Mediterranean, from
Morocco in the west to Egypt in the
east. Now, the Crusader enterprise, by
contrast, followed a radically different
approach. Christian armies did not have
a mandate to conquer all infidel lands
between Europe and Jerusalem. Their
objective was narrow, fixed, and
ideological, liberating the Holy Land
from Islamic tyranny. As a result, they
plunged directly into the heart of enemy
territory, establishing small Christian
states surrounded on all sides by vast
Muslim powers and populations. These
Crusader polities were not part of a
contiguous Christian realm, but isolated
enclaves which received irregular and
ever-dwindling support from Europe.
Lacking strategic depth, secure
land-based lines of communication, and a
substantial local manpower base,
certainly in comparison to their Muslim
neighbors, the Crusader states were
perpetually outnumbered. Any serious
defeat was catastrophic, as there was no
friendly hinterland into which they
could withdraw and recover. Losses could
not be easily replaced, while Muslim
forces could draw upon endless resources
and populations. When, for example,
Saladin was warned that King Richard the
Lionheart was preparing to winter in the
Holy Land in order to continue his
crusade, the Sultan boasted that, quote,
"If it is easy for him to winter here
and to be far from his family and
homeland, how easy is it for me to spend
a winter, a summer, then another winter,
and another summer in the middle of my
own lands, surrounded by my sons and my
family, when whatever and whoever I want
can come to me?" In short, the failure
of the Crusades was not the result of
insufficient courage or desire, far from
it, but of a structural mismatch between
idealistic objectives and material
realities. History's Muslim conquests
succeeded because they were flexible,
pragmatic, and geographically grounded.
Their first and foremost consideration
was to conquer any adjacent infidel
population once circumstances allowed.
The Crusader project, by contrast, was
bound to a single sacred objective
located deep within hostile territory,
and had nothing to do with conquering
infidels, but rather securing sacred
territory. From here, one can begin to
understand why the Crusades were indeed
heroic and inspiring. What's noteworthy
is not that they ultimately failed, but
that they managed to succeed under such
desperate circumstances for as long as
they did, nearly 200 years. Think about
it. That a small band of men, the
Crusaders, could persist for as long as
they did against ever-growing and
insurmountable odds is actually pretty
remarkable. To give you an idea of what
Muslims would have had to do to parallel
the Crusaders' achievement, imagine, if
you will, if Muslims, rather than
conquering infidel territories in
sequential, piecemeal fashion, as
discussed, had, say, after conquering
only Egypt, sailed directly to France,
conquered several of that nation's most
important coastal cities, and then
remained there, no matter what the
vastly numerical forces of all of Europe
did to eject them, for nearly two
centuries. Certainly, that would be an
achievement that the histories would
sing of. But, because it was Christians,
we're only supposed to talk and hear
about the negative, namely that they
ultimately lost, not that they did the
unthinkable for nearly 200 years, and
lost only due to the growing
secularization of Europe, which led to
even less support than before. Before
closing, I would be remiss not to
mention an interesting irony, a
modern-day twist to this discussion, one
that is currently unfolding. As it
happens, Muslims today are doing
precisely what the Crusaders did nearly
a thousand years ago. They, too, are
forming enclaves, ribats, even, right
smack in the middle of the enemy's
territory, namely Europe. The
difference, of course, is that they did
not accomplish this like the Crusaders,
that is, through force of arms, but
because they are being welcomed in with
open arms. And perhaps that's all you
need to know about history's Crusaders,
their modern-day descendants in Europe,
and the Muslims. The first two, the
Crusaders and their descendants, are the
mirror opposite of each other. The one
did everything to fight for, and the
other is doing everything to destroy,
the faith, while the ever-consistent
Muslims remain the same. Who's got
[music] the guts to bring back
the crusade?
>> [music]
>> Bring back [music]
the fire.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back
the fire
>> [music]
>> in the
righteous name.